in the summer of 1973 pollsters Lew
Harris and George Gallup began asking
people whether President Richard Nixon
should be impeached at that early point
in the Watergate saga most people did
not want to impeach the president public
opinion turned against Nixon in the late
spring of 1974 and Nixon resigned in
August now congressman brad Sherman
Democrat from California has filed an
impeachment resolution against Donald
Trump using language that is similar to
the resolutions language used during
Watergate measure has only one
co-sponsor and is unlikely to gain much
traction at this point what do the polls
say a July poll from Monmouth University
is pretty much in line with the small
handful of polls we have on the subject
in it 41% say President Trump should be
impeached and compelled to leave office
while 53% say that he should not be in
our deeply divided political environment
large majorities of Democrats want to
impeach him large majorities of
Republicans don't the third of
independents ad should go this is a
sensitive issue with serious political
ramifications let us know what you think
and let us know your comments also let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI